what is EDR the acronym stands for
endpoint detection and response which is
increasingly an essential part of any
competent cyber security strategy
over the next few minutes I'll go
through how it works and why it's so
essential these days
I'm Sam Hector from the IBM security
team and what I think EDR is really
doing is endpoint threat detection and
response
after all the point of EDR is not to go
around detecting all of the laptops
phones and servers on your network but
rather it's to proactively detect
threats on those endpoints when they
occur and respond to them in real time
to do this effectively it needs to do
four things really well
collect security data from the endpoints
using an agent which is a small
lightweight application that runs on
each of these devices to enable data
Gathering detection and then response
actions to take place even when that
endpoint isn't connected to the internet
it needs to collect security relevant
Telemetry like what processes are
running what servers are they connecting
to and what files are being accessed and
lots more information that can be useful
to detect the presence of a threat or to
use in forensic analysis and
investigation after an attack has
occurred
the second thing it needs to do is
detect and respond to threats in real
time and automatically
it does this mainly in two different
ways one for threats we've seen before
and one for threats we've never seen
when we detect attacks in the wild
security teams can gather what's called
indicators of compromise or iocs in
order to take a unique fingerprint of a
piece of malware like a ransomware tool
that's been around for a while for
example
in this case the EDR tool can act like
the bouncer on the door of a nightclub
denying entry to a list of Bad actors
before they even get in
traditionally this is what antivirus
would have been known for doing
but what about threats we've never seen
before or how would an EDR solution
protect against the growing number of
fileless attacks ones which never
download malicious malware or leave any
Trace well even threats we've seen
before use similar tactics and
techniques to past attacks we're already
aware of so in order to detect them
without a fingerprint it's a case of
using Advanced algorithms to look for
those behaviors
for example a really common method of
Distributing malware is by hiding it in
the macro code of an innocent looking
Microsoft Office file
an EDR tool could stop this by noticing
when the Excel application tries to
alter the system's security settings
something it would never normally need
to do so the EDR can block the attempt
before it's successful
the third thing it needs to enable is
forensic investigation and threat
hunting because I'm afraid to say that
no EDR tool will stop 100 of attacks but
by capturing lots of security relevant
information they can help security teams
understand how attacks were successful
and how to change their approach to
ensure they're detected and blocked in
the future
this can also enable security teams to
perform threat hunting activities to go
and proactively investigate all of their
endpoints at once for the presence of a
new threat that's not yet detected
automatically so they can manually take
action to reduce their risk
and finally an EDR tool needs to
integrate and Report
for a security analyst it needs to
integrate into their existing workflow
they're often inundated by alerts they
need to triage from lots of different
tools an EDR should help them prioritize
incidents to look at urgently present
them with all of the potentially
relevant information in a friendly
interface and speak the same language as
other security tools by adopting Common
vernacular like the miter attack
framework
for a security team an EDR tool needs to
integrate with all of their existing
capability and feed additional Telemetry
into a management platform like a Sim
tool for threat detection a saw tool for
instant response or an xdr platform that
combines these capabilities
it also needs to enable reporting both
on the importance of your organization's
mean time to respond to an attack but
also reporting against compliance to
regulatory Frameworks
so to finish if you're looking for an
EDR tool here's a few things you should
really look out for
the best ones like IBM's reactor will be
highly resilient to attack ideally by
being invisible and inaccessible to
running malware on the operating system
they should use Advanced AI to learn
from the decisions your analysts have
made in the past and recommend that in
future that alert is automatically
handled to drastically reduce the
analyst workload by more than 80 percent
they should have logging capabilities
that uses little data as possible to
save money on the cost of bandwidth and
offer multiple deployment models between
SAS on-prem and even air-gapped
environments to give you as much
flexibility as possible
to talk to IBM about adopting EDR or
even optimizing your approach click the
link in the description and get involved
in the conversation in the comments
below
check out our other cyber security
videos and subscribe to see more in the
future